so let me start by saying uh I have a
lot of questions and but I have to start
with um John and Bob
um what is it like having a childhood
best friend watching a childhood best
friend become a great actor and someone
who's been in Star Wars and dune I'm
terribly jealous and very bitter yeah so
bitter and I stalk him you know no it's
great man we we uh Oscar's been like
family most of our lives and to see him
do well is John and I cheer more than
anyone and we collect all the stuff with
his face on it so we can deface it and
we do what friends do you know in uh
dartboards and I have this anecdote
about how Talent it is when we were kids
and Ska band there's 12 people in that
band yeah and uh we all knew where to
stand we all some of us as well as what
to play
because of him he was all over it right
so that's like that was that indication
that just to drive man he was the great
director of a poor Orchestra exactly
um so I have to ask you did you give him
any feedback after that gif of ex
machina went viral of him dancing or did
you say no that was good we learned this
step so we could make fun of him later I
asked him if I could get a sex robot
that's true I did ask me if you could
get one of those yeah yeah I wanted my
own so you guys were in a band together
um and I'm curious when you look back
now are any of the songs any good or
were they all like oh boy we all need to
do a different career we were amazing
man the world was missing out we just
never figured out how great we were some
people figured that out yeah a lot of
the song still hold up it really doesn't
a good two doesn't love this yeah yeah
so for people that actually want to hear
them are they online yeah right there's
some YouTubers
songs and there's a Facebook page too
that has quite a bit of stuff yeah yeah
I read that you guys in the 90s also
worked or you know tried to create comic
books you know did a whole bunch of
things together are any of those ideas
that you did back then things you
actually want to pursue now that Oscar
has like a production company and can
actually make some of those things
happen
only in private
I mean we've been sharing stuff with
each other I mean ever since we first
met back in you know back in 94 or
whatever it was you know and so
um I was also just really excited to be
able to finally find a way uh to share
um you know Bob and John's unique voice
with a much broader audience in the you
know South Florida Scot scene in the 90s
sure
um Oscar individual
an individual question for you
um are you as someone who's been in Star
Wars are you watching Andor and are you
as impressed as I am I haven't been
watching it uh because I've just been
watching my kids poop mostly uh but um
but I'm excited I love it's amazing you
see it I'm with you I'm impressed it it
takes I don't know it's another it's a
different window into Star Wars right
it's amazing to watch like and you know
a Latino lead in Star Wars just like
running the whole you know the whole
show it's fantastic and I do you know
Gilroy you know he's hard to beat so I'm
excited to see it yeah it's uh it's the
best it's the best Star Wars show on
Disney plus by a mile Tony Gilroy is a
genius he really is
yeah he's he's amazing jumping into why
I actually get to talk to you guys
um for people that actually don't know
anything about the graphic novel
um what have you been telling people
about it like what's your log line that
you've been telling friends and family
it's it's about a detective
um who's rotten he's a rotten person
he's a bad cop he's a bad friend he's
you know a general piece of crap and
he has a higher purpose he has something
that he must achieve on this Earth and
he is not willing to change on his own
so higher Powers
um come in and kick him in the mouth
they help him they really help them they
shoot him in the head
um but nobody else can see the wound uh
and he is not going to the woman will
not ease until he starts to protect the
people he's supposed to he's getting the
wounds essentially of the people that he
is not protect people that he's not
serving so it's kind of like an enforced
empathy
and um that's that's Leo's Arc he's got
to become a better person and then
there's the concept of sparrow which is
for us we took it of course there's the
the biblical Sparrow the lowest form of
life is still loved by we said the
universe or God whatever you like and um
uh this idea of a spare was someone
who's been so beaten down that they are
not afraid anymore and he's beating
himself down he's he's giving he's given
himself this coat of scars but it's
still a hell of an armor as he's walking
toward what he has to do
um and so that's that's our concept and
behind that there's you know an
incredible world that that um John and
Bob have built of uh of spiritual
warfare spiritual classes within that uh
different hierarchies and it's it's
pretty profound how deep it goes and so
this is really the tip of the iceberg to
that whole story uh how did you guys
decide on the title and was it almost
something else
I think it was always headwinds it was
always head wounds
um because of the head wound
um the particular form of stigmata uh
it's also double meaning because [ __ ]
up head head wound yeah yeah
and then as you said the sparrow is you
know the kind of a rat with wings and uh
if if if that can have Redemption then
you know that's a that's a story we
totally missed out on Edwin's parrot and
it's all your fault it's true that would
be good the headlines flamingos
that's the next book okay stop giving it
away
uh Oscar I believe you produced this
through your production company
um imagine media um can you sort of talk
about what you're trying to accomplish
with your production company yeah just
giving our friends work basically
could you put talented in that sorry
sorry talented friends
yes yes very important uh no you know my
my wife Elvira Lind and I we just got
excited about you know we have a lot a
community of of artists and and uh
friends that are so creative and have
such unique voices and have a lot to say
and um and so we we really just got
excited about making a place making a
collective where those things can can
come to life and we can help each other
we can tease out
um all these stories that we have to
tell uh and so versus the fact that this
is the first real thing that you know
our company has officially put out into
the world and we couldn't be happier and
it couldn't be a better example of what
what we're trying to do I recently spoke
to piano and and some of his Partners
about his uh comic book called Berserker
and they are developing Berserker into
like an animated series of Netflix and a
live action movie Keanu told me he might
direct it
um for you guys and with this material
are you already thinking about you know
other mediums where you might take it or
is it sort of like one step at a time I
mean we're really excited about the ice
sculpture yeah version of head wounds
interpretive dance underwater basket
weaving this sort of thing yes
maybe like a a video game with Leo
versus Joker yeah demon and angel porn
oh I played too far I'm sorry the sky's
the limit basically sky is the limited
poor gutter
uh you know we'll see we'll see we'll
see if there's an audience for it we'll
see how people respond to it but but
there's a lot a lot of story to tell
yeah and that's something else I wanted
to know is when you are coming up with
it now for the graphic novel how much
are you already thinking about like the
long-term arc on where you would
ultimately like to go and how much are
you sort of just like well let's write
this and then we'll see what happens
and uh just the you know the the Bible
the characters the demons their powers
where the story Bible story Bible yeah
yeah yeah and uh every step that Leo
takes along the way to Redemption yeah
we thought about a lot there's more yeah
people are interested there's more we're
very sick people we uh we're D dorks
from you know a long time ago we Roll Up
characters we we make factions we create
worlds on a daily basis we were walking
around New York City thinking of of
role-playing scenes in the alleys and
um all kind of [ __ ] so we'd never stop
and Leo's the same way this head wound
Sparrow John and I are every day coming
up with ideas and the world is already
made and it's tailor-made for more I'm
curious what do you think would surprise
people to learn about the making of a
graphic novel
maybe just how that's not surprising but
just how [ __ ] exciting it is when
Christian Ward would send us a new
drawing you know like every every few
weeks and get a new panel and it just
the giddiness that would occur to see
you know these things that we've talked
about for a long time I mean especially
for Bob and John you know to have it
just come to life in such an expressive
and beautiful way
um I mean just the art book The Art in
this book alone is is is astounding and
I'd say worth the price of admission yes
yeah I had to find new words because I
found myself emailing him every two
weeks when we got pictures this is so
badass this is so badass and after about
a month I was like I need something else
I would say my own sick fantasies and
you know in paintings and drawings that
you know belonged on the Sistine Chapel
ceiling so
um the guy's amazing he's it even
transcends comic book art the guy is an
amazing artist if it's wrong and he's
got the soul for it anything surprising
working with Brian I just Brian taught
us not to be so up our own asks
um we were we're just learning uh to do
this right which a lot of the writer
totally yeah so we were talking to Brian
and he's like why are you using this big
word here and you know he taught us to
to bring it back down so that we were
working with other people instead of
trying to prove we were smarter than the
next person who might read this and
we're you know eternally thankful for
that lesson Brian bujuleta is also uh
buchellado is also a badass yeah sure
yeah I'm also curious obviously you guys
played D when you were younger what is
it like for you guys
don't play Wednesday Wednesdays every
Everything Tuesdays and Wednesdays yeah
oh for real yes sir for real yeah yeah
um so uh I I know a lot of people
including uh I know a lot of people who
are still playing I'm just curious what
is what has it been like for my alarm to
go off what has it been like for uh to
see the like the popularity of D and D
sort of like especially the last few
years it seems like it's exponentially
gotten bigger do you remember what it
was like being a nerd in the 90s and not
telling anyone that you were reading ra
Salvatore that you were addicted to
faerun and putting maps and Forgotten
Realms on your wall that it's amazing
everyone's a nerd now or at least it's
okay you know it's terrible yeah
I was an ogre and so I got away with
saying you know I I love Mel and the
bone or you know I'm reading it's
stormbringer and and telling everyone
about it in school and I was bigger than
them so they couldn't beat me up but
um no now it's great man I love that
they're opening up to everyone they're
making it more accessible to different
types of people to create different
types of characters that the systems
we're working on have really opened up
it's crazy like a almost culturally uh
and subculturally for everybody to be
able to create the character that they
want within those systems and play their
fantasy whatever the hell that is and
that is badass man we've loved seeing
the the evolution of that stuff uh Oscar
before I run out of time with you I
definitely have to ask you uh as a fan
of your performance in Moon Knight and
the series I mean I feel like I've been
teased about a season two but it it's
confirmed but it's not confirmed can we
just definitively say that you are
making Moon night season too I'll give
it to him we can't definitively say that
I need my teasing abilities you can't
drain me of those little cocktails I am
uh
always been
that's true
uh no I hope so you know we'll see we'll
see what happens but at the moment
there's no there's no official official
word
I'll tell you that listen I I really did
love your performance in the series and
obviously I want to see you doing more
of this uh
um I want to follow up but I have really
no I mean I can see you're not going to
give it up what let me I guess I'll ask
you what are you possibly filming in the
upcoming future
possibly filming my children pooping
I've got enough pictures uh nothing
there's nothing in the in the works I
took I you know Moon Knight was so
amazing but also so incredibly draining
I just put every bit of myself into that
every bit of output I could that it's
just been a it's been a year of input
just taking stuff in as opposed to
having to put anything thing out
um other than headphones
uh but but so so at the moment I'm gonna
do a play next year
and then and then we'll see we'll see
what happens after that
um how did you guys end up with
legendary comics and did you you know
was it what is it like negotiating with
a company like that and how much are
they sort of saying when they sign on
hey we want to have the merchandise we
want to have you know like um how does
it all work in terms of that negotiation
of thinking about long-term IP and you
know what I mean and getting into bed
with the company yeah well we you know
there's a lot of intimidation involved
they've been they were awesome well I
was I was shooting doom and and that's
when we first really started talking
about it and uh it was you know kale
boiter over there uh I brought him this
story first started talking to him about
it and he kind of opened the door up and
then we started talking to to Robert uh
Robert Robert Hampton is amazing at
legendary comics and that's where like
the idea really started picking up some
steam and uh and they were just so who
um how generous in in the way that they
approach this so helpful and so excited
about the creative part of it and making
it come to life uh and so uh yeah as far
as the ins and outs of of the deal I'd
be happy to connect you with my lawyer
right okay
but no it was uh it was it was nothing
but uh Robert is our Gandalf uh Yoda
yeah like not that ugly but you know
that type of he guided Us in this medium
majorly without him we would have been
lost as hell
um so the guy's a brilliant guy and he
helped us a ton yeah we're excited to
continue that relationship
on that note I'm just going to say
congratulations on your first thing
together and uh I wish you guys nothing
but the best and I hope it's a huge hit